you know what i love about khabib is
that he was always proud of his reason
he loved khabib because he's very proud
of his faith and he's never shied away
from it so
we're we're meeting here this is the uh
his name is by the way good night
actually
if you guys need anything please you
know we're here for you okay thank you
all right guys
my father told me
we living on this life not to become
good athletes not to become like
like go to teachers or something we're
living this life to be a good muslim and
if you've got some advice for us the
advice i have is to always uh honor your
guest and you have honored me by
contacting me and having this lunch
together
thank you so much really
i've been drinking music for 20 plus
years grappling wrestling just like you
i met you seven years ago in vegas my
corner of guys in ufc also
what can you say
to motivate more muslims out here and
these kids to do jujitsu like the
prophet used to wrestle
i think us muslims you guys are
complaining about all this stuff but why
aren't you guys grappling and wrestling
and building that confidence that i have
and that the beef has
that i think more muslims should be
training jiu jitsu in wrestling ensemble
i wish i could learn ensemble in chicago
but we don't have it
but uh what can you say to motivate the
youth and uh the dean show's still
waiting for you
it's
[Applause]
i think i think
i think this is all about parents
we have to we have to teach them how to
compete because this is
this is teach
kids mentality you know this is very
good jiu-jitsu you cover your body you
grateful this is sunnah for sure because
prophet muhammed
of course he wrestles
and i think this is very good for kids
if they're gonna training every week
like people time
[Music]
yep
paper rock says it shoots guys that's
one that's one out of three that's the
three out of five all right whatever you
want let's go paper rock and shoot oh
all right that's two that's two
paper boxes and shoot
whatever i didn't twitch
it's the same time i figured i'd keep
her in the same way the same team
brother vic jujitsu keep training you
guys butts off yeah train hard i'll see
you tomorrow take care man
just call me bruce guys but a big shout
out to everybody a team reservic okay
do it good do it strong train safe train
hard be tough what's up team rezvik keep
kicking some butt